non
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo le magazine des temps
forts de l'actualité de la semaine à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat avec
un mec côté thibault enoch mon gentil
bon bonjour auriol et cette semaine
notre invité est tard j'ai marseille mon
jour sénateur des hauts-de-seine et vous
êtes le président du groupe union
centriste au sénat merci d'être avec
nous et dans l'actualité cette semaine
il y a d'abord ses divisions de la
majorité sur la hausse de la csg pour
les retraités
une poignée de députés en marche et
opposés au gouvernement en proposant
qu'elle soit progressive
une première même si ses députés
refusent de parler de fronde le point de
départ de la retraite à points le haut
commissaire à la réforme des retraites
jean paul delevoye était auditionné au
sénat cette semaine c'est le premier
rang d'une réforme hautement sensible
censé aboutir en 2019
jean paul delevoye esquissé les grandes
lignes du nouveau système mais beaucoup
de questions restent encore en suspens
et puis ambiance explosive à l'assemblée
c'était mercredi au sein de la mission
d'information sur la bioéthique les
députés ont notamment auditionner la
manif pour tous une audition qui a donné
le ton tendue des débats à venir entre
pro et anti pma port tout et on commence
cette semaine avec la loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale examinée à
l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des débats marqués par des divisions
internes à la majorité c'est assez rare
pour être signalé certains députés de la
république en marche ont plaidé pour la
mise en place d'une csg progressive pour
les retraités afin d'épargner davantage
les plus modestes
le gouvernement n'a guère apprécié cette
remise en cause alors que la mesure est
déjà politiquement sensible le résumé
des débats de la semaine est signée elsa
monde un gars va dans l'examen du budget
de la sécurité sociale
deux sigles ont été au coeur des débats
le théaux 2e tout d'abord pour
travailleurs occasionnels et demandeurs
d'emploi
c'est à dire les saisonniers qui
travaillent dans le secteur agricole
jusqu'à présent leurs employeurs étaient
exonérés de charges sociales mais le
gouvernement entend revenir sur ce
dispositif
ce que dénoncent les oppositions mais où
est-on où est-on pour des gens qui se
lèvent tous les matins qui travaillent
plus de 50 heures par semaine
lorsqu'il y à la saison des cueillettes
et du ramassage des fruits et des
légumes
c'est indécent ce que vous faites là
monsieur le ministre il faut donner les
moyens à nos producteurs de fruits et
des légumes d'être compétitif ou alors
est-ce qu'on tire un trait sur notre
production de fruits et légumes est ce
qu'on fait en sorte qu' on le dit très
explicitement qu'il ya de la place pour
les marocains qui a de la place pour les
espagnols mais qui a plus de place pour
les français c'est ça l'enjeu
le gouvernement maintient cette
suppression mais fait adopter un
amendement pour en atténuer les effets
autre sujet de discorde la csg les
oppositions déplore la baisse du pouvoir
d'achat que connaissent un certain
nombre de retraités avec la hausse de la
csg mais plus rares les critiques
viennent aussi de députés la république
en marche
donc oui à un moment où sincèrement et
je le dis bien il n'ya pas les retraités
il ya des retraités et on ne peut pas
considérer que le retraité cta 1200
euros ne peut pas faire le doit faire le
même effort que suite à 3000 3500 et
4000 le patron du groupe appel à la
discipline aujourd'hui augmenter moduler
modifier la csg cela équivaut à trahir
une promesse politique
que nous avons fait pendant la campagne
conscient de l'impopularité de sa mesure
le gouvernement a tout de même proposé
un amendement pour exonérer 350 mille
foyers de retraités de la hausse de la
csg
autre mesure adoptée dans ce budget de
la sécurité sociale la désocialisation
des heures supplémentaires et la
transformation du cic eux le crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi en baisse
de charge la fin mars à une csg
progressive pour épargner les petites
retraites la mesure a été rejeté à
l'assemblée est ce que c'est une mesure
que vous pourriez soutenir au sénat oui
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut discuter
enfin vous voyez où on en est arrivés on
s'étonne qu'il puisse y avoir des débats
au parlement
c'est bien le sujet je veux dire le
gouvernement et le président de la
république ne respecte pas le parlement
a le parlement il est là pour discuter
la loi et la beauté on n'est pas là pour
faire du prêt à voter on n'amène pas un
texte en disant voilà c'est à prendre ou
à laisser
enfin on est émerveillé de voir qu'il ya
des députés y compris de la république
en marche
qui ose discuter le texte et qui ose
l'amendé bon à un moment donné je veux
dire ça je sais pas où on va mais ça
devient terrible il va y avoir bientôt
une réforme institutionnelle - de
parlementaires on se demande jusqu'où ça
va aller
c'est vrai qu'un parlementaire s'est
fait quand même pour discuter la loi
c'est fait pour faire des amendements
c'est fait pour faire des propositions
le gouvernement n'écoute rien vous
entendez monsieur legendre qui dit il ya
une espèce de deux textes sacrés c'est
une promesse du président voilà il vous
la mène donc circulez ya rien à voir
je sais pas combien de temps ça va durer
alors tous les cas c'est pas supportable
gouvernement dira on a déjà fait un pas
sur cette question en exonérant 350
mille retraités de cette hausse de la
csg les plus modestes
est-ce que ce ça va assez loin c'est un
premier pas mais on voit bien que cette
mesure est impopulaire c'est d'ailleurs
le sujet que ce soit pour le budget
social comme pour le budget
le projet de loi de finances on va où
c'est quoi la politique du gouvernement
le budget ce soit le budget social ou le
budget général
il traduit la politique du gouvernement
on voit bien aujourd'hui dans l'est sont
là je vois des farceurs et retraités
cette politique
oui on voit pas quelle est la politique
globale du gouvernement c'est ça le
sujet c'est que d'un côté on vous dit on
veut plus de pouvoir d'achat mais on
baisse la paix l on supprime la taxe
d'habitation etc
et puis de l'autre côté on taxe le
diesel plein pot on amène tout un tas de
redevances
les gens voient pas très bien où on voir
on sait pas si on veut plus de pouvoir
d'achat ou si au contraire on cherche de
l'argent pour le budget et donc quand on
touche à la csg comme on l'a fait
vis-à-vis des retraités et des retraités
les plus modestes
on voit bien la levée de boucliers qui a
donc cherché des solutions pour que les
retraités les plus modestes soit moins
affectés par cette situation
c'est pas une mauvaise chose alors
pardon le gouvernement dit notamment hui
les retraités effectivement ils vont ils
vont être mises à contribution mais il
ya aussi des gestes qui sont faits pour
eux par exemple reste à charge 0 pour
les lunettes les prothèses dentaires les
prothèses auditives mais cette semaine
une étude d'un cabinet a estimé que les
tarifs des mutuelles finalement allé à
les augmenter en raison de cette mesure
le gouvernement dit ce n'est pas vrai
qui croyez vous je crois plutôt le
cabinet en question ont regardé la taxe
d'habitation on a dit on va supprimer la
taxe d'habitation
et puis cette année vous allez peut-être
gens qui disent j'ai lu ce que j'ai reçu
et finalement j'ai payé plus cher
pourquoi parce qu'il ya toujours des
effets aux mesures annoncées est donc
une semaine n'a pas suffisamment préparé
sa mesure et bien suffisamment financé
c'est pas dialoguer je veux dire sur
toutes ces mesures il n'y a pas de
dialogue avec le parlement avec les
corps intermédiaires
on est dans un système où tout vient
d'en haut
tout vient d'en haut et donc on le voit
bien à travers les sondages si le
président de la république enregistre
aujourd'hui une mauvais sondages c'est
parce que c'est lui qui se met en avant
surtout certes c'est très bien il dit
j'assume mais on le voit partout
asko balle dans le nord c'est lui qui va
me veut c'est pas le premier ministre et
quant à gérald darmanin il a disparu
falloir faire une alerte enlèvement
prochainement et donc
je veux dire c'est normal qu'à partir de
là les choses ne soient pas préparés qui
est évidemment des conséquences non
prévisible parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de
dialogue et en particulier avec le
parlement allez on en vient à notre
deuxième thème cette audition mercredi
de jean paul delevoye sur la réforme des
retraites
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est devant la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat que le haut
commissaire à la réforme des retraites a
été auditionné deux semaines après avoir
dévoilé les premières pistes de la
réforme
il a tenté de répondre aux inquiétudes
des sénateurs mais sans trop en dire non
plus alors que les arbitrages ne sont
pas encore rendus samia déchire les
pistes de la réforme des retraites sont
déjà connus ce jean paul delevoye les a
dévoilés aux partenaires sociaux il y a
deux semaines
auditionné par la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat
il n'a rien dévoilé de nouveaux je
comprends bien que habitude qui consiste
à dire vous avez décidé quoi
eh bien j'ai simplement décidé d'engager
le dialogue avec un objectif très clair
de mettre en place un système universel
les discussions vont se poursuivre
pendant six mois mais certains points
sont déjà actés le futur système de
retraite sera le même pour tous les
français
dans ce système par points 1 euro cotisé
ouvrira les mêmes droits pour tous et
l'âge minimum restera fixé à 62 ans
cela donc m.pelli qu'une disparition des
quarante deux je crois système de
retraite pour converger vers un système
unique ont effectivement c'est quelque
chose que
tout le monde appelle de ses voeux
depuis bien longtemps mais que personne
oser oser faire et c'est un vrai défi
est vrai challenge
voilà pour les grandes lignes mais après
l'audition les sénateurs restent dans
l'expectative
dans ce futur système de retraite par
points aucun travailleur ne peut pour
l'instant savoir si le montant de sa
pension risque de diminuer on ne pourra
pas juger tant qu'on ne saura pas
comment sera calculé la valeur du point
par qui elle sera calculée à kehl à quel
moment elle sera éventuellement
revisiter le calcul dépendra en effet de
la forme de gouvernance qui sera retenu
pour le futur système des retraites
autre incertitude comment seront
financés les périodes d'interruption
d'activité comme le chômage la plupart
des questions ne sont en réalité pas
encore tranché après marseille cette
réforme des retraites c'est une réforme
que vous allez soutenir pour savoir ce
qu'il ya dedans pour l'instant c'est on
en est aux prémices
effectivement comme cela vient d'être
dit simplifié rationaliser donner plus
de cohérence tout le monde souhaite que
ce soit plus lisible c'est évident après
le système par points c'est très bien
comme on vient de le dire dans le
reportage comment on calcule la valeur
du point
parce que si vous voulez savoir ce que
vous toucherez il faut qu'on sache
comment ces calculs et par qui et quels
en sont les conditions
alors il ya toujours une appréhension
parce que quand un gouvernement vous dis
on va réformer les retraites vous dit
quelque chose me dit qu'on va pas
toucher plus de retraite dans un pays
très endetté avec des perspectives
économiques qui sont à peu préoccupantes
on se dit quelque part que un risque
d'en toucher moins voilà il ya un risque
d'en toucher moins c'est pour ça qu'il
faut être très attentif à la façon dont
ça va être fait là encore il ya du
dialogue par monsieur delevoye c'est
très bien mais il faut pas que
l'exécutif une fois encore se mêlent de
tout il ya quelques semaines on se
souvient du débat sur les pensions de
réversion
on n'a pas de
réponse à ça même le président a dit on
ne touche pas au système des pensions de
réversion pour ceux qui en touche
aujourd'hui pour l'avenir on sait pas
donc je crois qu'il faut être
extrêmement attentif très prudent et
surtout là encore il faut qu'ils aient
des échanges avec les syndicats avec les
associations avec les corps
intermédiaires et surtout être le
parlement alors il ya un indicateur qui
est connue ce sera l'âge légal 62 ans
minimum pour le départ à la retraite est
ce que cet âge vous convient oui cet âge
est un âge raisonnable bien sûr pour des
raisons à la fois budgétaire économique
mais aussi démographique on sait très
bien que l'allongement de la vie est un
fait acquis
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs qui sont désireux de
travailler davantage ça n'empêche pas ce
qu'il ne fallait pas augmenter sa taille
légale de départ la retraite 62 ans
c'est un âge convenable il faut pouvoir
le faire par paliers il faut que ce soit
acceptable
c'est un âge a priori qui peut être
accepté par beaucoup 62 ans
ceux qui veulent arrêter avant pourront
le faire vraisemblablement mais avec un
taux de retraite évidemment qu'il sera
pas plein après d'autres voudront
continuer à travailler parce que s'ils
trouveront leurs intérêts leurs
avantages leur satisfaction
je crois que que sur l'âge c'est une
bonne chose c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
permet c'est un des facteurs qui permet
aujourd'hui au budget social d'être en
équilibre pour la première fois donc je
crois que c'est quelque chose vers
lequel on peut aller mais il ya encore
beaucoup d'inconnues et ça va être un
gros débat quelque chose me dit
d'ailleurs que ça va être un peu reporté
à cause des élections européennes et que
attendre un peu pour arriver aux sujets
les plus chauds et vous pensez qu'il y
aura des perdants dans cette réforme
forcément forcément et quel jeu sait pas
encore lesquels mais je veux dire par
définition si certains touchent plus ou
mieux d'autres toucheront un peu moins
donc c'est il va falloir être très
vigilants sur ces sujets on va revenir à
notre troisième thème pro et anti pma se
sont affrontées cette semaine à
l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était mercredi matin les députés de la
mission d'information sur la révision de
la loi de bioéthique qui devraient
notamment prévoir une extension de la
pma toutes les femmes ont auditionné
successivement sos homophobie la manif
pour tous et l'association sos vite à
des débats parfois tendus qui ont donné
le ton peut être des mois à venir
puisque la loi devrait être présenté
d'ici à la fin de l'année rabhi cas
d'entrée de jeu guillaume chiche donne
le ton j'ai adressé un courrier au
président de la présente mission et à
son rapporteur pour m'opposer
formellement un votre audi si vous avez
employé le mot cours d'année monsieur
chiche donc vous refuser le débat
l'écoutent
le dialogue est bien cela n'engage que
vous comme lui le président de sos
homophobie évoque la crainte d'une
nouvelle explosion de violence il
rappelle qu'en 2012 les actes homophobes
avait augmenté de 78%
nous ce qu'on demande vraiment c'est
d'être de c2c de légiférer sur la main
le plus rapidement possible pour
justement éviter que cette éviter cette
montée de violence homophobe dans le
débat public mais aussi dans le pays
la possible ouverture de la procréation
médicalement assistée pour les couples
de femmes et aux femmes seules inquiète
les associations anti pma elle pointe
les conséquences de l'absence de père
sur les enfants la magistrate dominique
marcilhacy indique par exemple que 80%
des mineurs qui passe au tribunal en
comparution immédiate n'ont pas ou plus
de lien avec leur père je dois dire que
nous sommes particulièrement attentifs
alliance vita premier matic liée à
l'absence de père et nous accompagnons
des femmes enceintes qui se pose avec
angoisse la question de poursuivre une
grossesse quand le père s'en va et parce
que le l'enfant ne connaîtra pas
justement son père sur cette question
sos homophobie dénonce un préjugé jamais
on ne s'est dit oui mais une femme qui
adopteraient seul n'aurait pas de
référent paternel à ses côtés donc
qu'aujourd'hui cette question elles
reviennent uniquement sur nous et nos
familles c'est vrai que c'est ça fait
partie aussi dessous de ce qu'on disait
du climat ambiant qui vise à stigmatiser
nos familles en disant regardez elles
sont différentes
d'autres inquiétudes ont été soulevées
par les associations anti pma comme
l'anonymat du don de sperme ou encore le
risque de marchandisation de gamme mais
le gouvernement l'a récemment confirmé
la pma pour toutes les femmes sera bien
inclus dans le futur projet de loi
bioéthique qui sera débattu à
l'assemblée début 2019 le projet de loi
de révision des lois bioéthique sera
donc débattu au parlement au premier
semestre 2010 9 est ce que vous voterez
un vrai marseille en faveur de la pma
pour toutes les femmes couture d'abord
voir le texte pour l'instant on ne
connaît pas le textile pour ce sujet de
la peine c'est un sujet éminemment
intime je crois que sur des sujets comme
comme ceux là sont pas des sujets qu'on
vote par groupe
il ya une liberté de votre totale dans
notre groupe est évidemment chacun
se fera son idée en conscience elle est
la vôtre
personnellement sur la pma suivant les
débats et suivants l'encadrement
je n'exclus pas de voter cette cette
avance est pas là pas la gpa mais sur la
pma je peux comprendre
je peux comprendre la situation d'un
certain nombre de couples je peux
comprendre la façon dont ces vécu
intimement par des hommes et des femmes
qui veulent avoir des enfants pour
l'instant c'était extrêmement limité aux
couples hétérosexuels à fertile on peut
faire progresser ce cadre mais il faut
beaucoup d'encadrement beaucoup de
précautions on voit bien aujourd'hui les
difficultés dans beaucoup de familles on
parle on n'a pas certainement après des
difficultés dans certains établissements
scolaires où il ya des montées de
violence si on voit bien que comme cela
a été dit dans le reportage que que
beaucoup de jeunes qui sont sujets à ces
violences qui sont auteurs de violences
vivent dans des conditions familiales
qui sont pas satisfaisantes donc il faut
faire très attention à la façon dont on
va permettre à des hommes et des femmes
d'avoir des enfants dans certains cas
alors que la loi ne le permet pas
aujourd'hui je crois que sur tous ces
sujets avec les neurosciences
l'identité des donneurs l'intelligence
artificielle en matière médicale il faut
avancer avec beaucoup de modestie
beaucoup de précautions prendre le temps
parce que là on rentre dans des domaines
vraiment difficile très inconnu et qui
peuvent nous mener très loin alors
difficile politiquement socialement le
gouvernement veut à tout prix éviter que
se reproduise le scénario du du mariage
pour tous est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est possible d'éviter un nouvel
affrontement sociétal sur cette question
c'est l'objectif qu'il faut rechercher
je crois que ce sont des sujets qui
concernent chacune et chacun d'entre
nous sont pas des sujets qui doivent
donner lieu à des positions binaire
politique avec ce qui serait absolument
pour ceux qui seraient absolument contre
je crois que la ligne de fracture
traverse l'ensemble des formations
politiques et des courants de pensée
je crois qu'il faut encore une fois
travaillé les uns avec les autres pour
essayer de dégager des solutions les
plus larges possibles et qui rassemble
le plus on est dans une société dans un
monde qui évolue très vite avec
une vie numérique qui avance encore plus
vite et qui ouvre des débouchés
extrêmement important donc la loi elle
doit essayer justement de d'avancé en
même temps que la science en même temps
que la société est en même temps elle
doit mettre des garde-fous pour qu'on
aille pas vers la marchandisation du
corps et vers des dérives absolument
insupportable justement est ce que ces
garde-fous sont suffisants vous êtes
contraints de gpa vous l'avez dit les
opposants du texte aux textes disent à
court terme c'est exclu puisque le
gouvernement a clairement dit qu'il n'y
aura pas la gpa dans ce texte mais à
moyen terme ce n'est pas exclue est-ce
que vous aussi vous redoutez ça mais
justement c'est la dérive c'est c'était
les débats qu'on avait au moment de de
ce qu'on a appelé le mariage pour tous
c'était que on n'a pas tout dit on n'a
pas suffisamment été jusqu'au bout du
raisonnement je veux pas refaire le
débat il a été long le problème c'était
pas que que des hommes ou des femmes de
même sexe puissent consacrer leur vie
collective leur vie ensemble
c'était la suite et s'était inscrit
presque à travers les lois et les prises
de positions européennes
donc on est déjà maintenant à la phase
suivante c'est la pma c'est pas normal
et c'est quelque chose encore une fois
qui mérite qu'on s'y arrête
en revanche pour la gpa là on rentre
vraiment autre chose
alors mardi le sénat a adopté la réforme
de la justice dans une version largement
remaniée mais l'actualité de la semaine
et notamment cette enseignante braquer
par un élève a rouvert le débat sur l'
ordonnance de 1945 sur la justice des
mineurs
pour gérard larcher une nouvelle loi est
indispensable et sur notre antenne la
garde des sceaux
nicole belloubet dit ne pas fermer la
porte à une révision l'écoutent
il me semble qu'il ne serait pas
inintéressant d'avoir un débat sur ce
texte parce qu' il manque de cohérence
et sans doute pourrions-nous
avantageusement le réinterroger je dis
cela parce que des sénateurs se sont
déjà emparés de ce sujet sont venus me
voir pour me présenter un travail qu'ils
avaient eu l'occasion de faire dans ce
cadre-là sur les jeunes et donc je sais
également qu'il ya des députés qui
s'intéressent à ce sujet
c'est donc quelque chose peut-être que
nous pourront effectivement réouvrir le
moment venu la marseillaise que vous
êtes favorable à une révision de
l'ordonnancé de 1945 est ce qu'il faut
abaisser la majorité pénale à 16 ans
comme le demandent par exemple bruno
retailleau
alors il faut qu'on ait le débat touché
à au texte de 45 certainement c'est un
texte d'après guerre c'était une
génération qui arrivait alors qu'on
sortait de la deuxième guerre mondiale
je crois que en 2018 maintenant on est
loin de tout ça la société encore une
fois beaucoup évolué il faut qu'on
puisse essayer de trouver des solutions
c'est très difficile c'est très
difficile parce que ce sont des débats
qu'on a déjà eu et se contenter de dire
qu'il faut de la fermeté je crois qu
évidemment tout le monde se dit qu'il
faut d'autorité mais est ce que pour
autant mettre des policiers dans les
écoles policiers qu'on n'a pas on a pas
on peut pas d'un côté dire faut faire
des économies avoir moins de
fonctionnaires puis l'autre côté dire
fois falloir embaucher des policiers
pour les mettre dans les écoles
couper les allocations familiales on a
déjà eu ces débats ça ne mène nulle part
c'est compliqué je crois qu'il faut
effectivement redonner aux professeurs
l'autorité qui doit être la leur il faut
pouvoir sanctionner les dérives y
compris devant les tribunaux et il faut
trouver des formules mais souvent
l'abaissement de la majorité pénale sur
l'abaissement de la majorité pénale
moi je suis pas très chaud pour cet
abaissement
il faut voir dans quelles conditions et
qu'elles seraient des conséquences de
cet abaissement
parce qu'encore une fois on peut pas
judiciariser l'ensemble des problèmes de
la société
il faut surtout trouver les moyens parce
que chaque fois qu'on dit on va faire
quelque chose ça coûte faire des
établissements spécialisés avoir des
professeurs spécialisés des encadrants
des surveillants et c'est ça coûte
il faut surtout qu'on puisse dégager les
moyens allez on poursuit notre tour
d'horizon de la semaine parlementaire
avec ce vote important celui de la
première partie du budget 2010 9 après
une semaine de débats dans l'hémicycle
les députés ont adopté très largement le
volet recettes du projet de loi de
finances les députés de la république en
marche et du modem ont voté pour ceux de
la gauche et des républicains pour voter
contre le texte prévoit notamment une
baisse
6 milliards d'impôts pour les ménages et
près de 20 milliards pour les
entreprises l'assemblée va maintenant se
pencher sur le volet des dépenses pour
un vote final du budget le 20 novembre
prochain le budget en tout cas cette
partie recette va maintenant arriver au
sénat hervé marseille
quelles vont être vos angles d'attaqué
sur ce texte bah le budget gelé dit tout
à l'heure c'est la traduction de la
politique du gouvernement
on voit pas très bien aujourd'hui quelle
est cette politique il faudrait que le
gouvernement clarifie un peu ses
objectifs
il veut quoi le gouvernement en matière
énergétique
on devrait avoir prochainement des
débats qu'est ce qu'on fait on fait de
la fiscalité écologique mais en même
temps c'est pas trop sur l'atome si on
ferme les centrales si on fait des opm
etc
on fait quoi je veux dire en matière
sociale on est en train d idées on veut
redonner du pouvoir d'achat en même
temps on fait des économies on voit pas
très bien où on va il était annoncé
puisqu'on fait grand cas des promesses
du président de la république pendant la
campagne présidentielle
tout le monde avait reconnu qu'on était
très endettée 2300 milliards de dette
ça augmente encore tous les ans on a un
peu plus de déficit alors il ya
certainement des raisons à tout ça mais
comment on fait aujourd'hui on voit pas
ça la baisse du nombre des
fonctionnaires
cinquante mille sur le mandat en est à
peine à moins 6000 aujourd'hui on fait
quoi donc à la fois beaucoup de
préoccupations d'incertitude d'ambiguïté
il faut qu'on ait une vision un peu plus
claire de ce que veut le gouvernement
on termine très rapidement un fait
marseille par une proposition la
communiste qui a fait débat cette
semaine au sénat il visait à revaloriser
l'allocation adulte handicapé et elle a
été rejetée par le sénat qui l'a juste
sous financé les communistes en colère
ont décidé de publier la liste des
sénateurs qui ont voté contre cette
proposition de loi est ce que c'est une
pratique qui vous inquiète
oui c'est très inquiétant parce que
cette technique qui consiste à montrer
du doigt ceux dont on considère qu'ils
ont mal voté ou qu'ils ont dit des ils
ont tenu des propos qui ne plaisent pas
ben ça conduit à ce que vous voyez aux
etats unis aujourd'hui c'est à dire
avoir des élus ou des personnalités qui
reçoivent des bombes
en attendant mieux certainement donc une
pratique inquiétante merci beaucoup
merci à marseille d'avoir été à cette
semaine avec nos aînés nous t-bonds se
retrouve dans deux semaines pour un
nouveau numéro de parlement de merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi
[Musique]